si l'europe ne comprends pas qu'elle
doit se prendre en main militairement au
lieu de faire confiance aveuglément aux
etats unis elle est en mauvais état
[Musique]
il ya une grande différence entre des
taliban et des shs d'âge c'était un
mouvement très exogènes par rapport à la
syrie un peu moins l'irak car une grande
partie des dirigeants et têtes irakiens
que c'était un mouvement jihadiste
international comme l'était el qaïda les
talibans sont d'abord un mouvement
national aux islamistes repeat mans
afghans et dans une certaine mesure
pakistanais leurs volontés
d'intervention à travers le monde et
moins essentiel pour eux c'est le
contrôle de la cie que tu suis d'oise
est en tout cas il devrait être moins
actif comme force de terrorisme
international le principal problème de
savoir quels seront leurs relations avec
l'iran les relations avec l'iran vont
sans doute être très compliqué parce que
les talibans qui sont déçus ni des
extrémistes et très rigoriste
considèrent les chiites comme des
hérétiques
épouvantable autant c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour les états unis autant ça
risque d'être aussi une assez mauvaise
nouvelle pour monsieur pas ici le
nouveau président iranien
il y a quelques années à mes collègues
avaient rencontré au pakistan patron
d'une maîtresse à sète une école
religieuse qui formait des enfants de 5
ans enfant de talibans afghans et il
leur a dit opérer dans quinze ans ce
seront les futurs talibans qui
reprendront kaboul et qui ensuite
lutteront contre l'occident et
effectivement cette prédiction s'est
réalisé ces jeunes qui ont repris kaboul
aujourd'hui quittant pour la plupart
d'entre eux ont une vingtaine d'années
ce sont des talibans afghans qui ont été
formés dans l'exil dans les mènerait sa
et talibans pakistanais pour l'islamisme
sunnite dans le monde c'est évidemment
quelque chose de formidable le faire
leur permettent de casser toute l'espèce
de dépression qui s'était installée
après la défaite de dave soudain de
nouveau le mouvement islamiste
international sunnite a connu une
victoire militaire que ce que les
talibans vont en faire je ne pense pas
qu'ils diot logiquement ils échangeaient
cette jeune génération a été formaté de
la même manière que l'ancienne mais ils
vont devoir s'adapter à un contexte
géopolitique nouveau pia deux semaines à
peu près l'état major talibans étaient
reçus en grand tralala à pékin les
chinois voilà quelque chose qui peut
affaiblir les etats-unis est ce que les
talibans vont vouloir s'intégrer dans
les nouvelles routes de la soie chinoise
est ce que ce sera une route de l'opium
si vous voulez qu'il ira vers la chine
wire vont se trouver en tout cas
confrontés à une géopolitique qui a
changé aujourd'hui l'affrontement
mondial c'est plus entre le bloc
soviétique et les états unis mais c'est
entre la chine
commerçants et les états unis et
l'occident
l'europe n'est pas vraiment protéger
tant qu'elle est désunie aujourd'hui on
devrait
réfléchir à l'efficacité du parapluie
militaire américain en afghanistan une
fois que le parapluie a été refermé il
n'y a plus personne pour sauver
l'aghanistan des talibans si l'europe ne
comprends pas qu'elle doit se prendre en
main militairement au lieu de faire
confiance aveuglément aux etats unis
elle est en mauvais état une échéance
importante sera le sommet du med 7 c'est
à dire des sept pays méditerranéens de
culture gréco-latine de l'union
européenne qui se tiendra en craintes au
moins de septembre dans lequel ces pays
qui seront les premières victimes et
flux renouveler d'immigration en
provenance d'asie centrale ont de voir à
quel ces pays vont devoir faire face
l'europe ne peut pas être simplement
réceptacle de tous les problèmes qui se
produisent dans le monde sans avoir la
capacité elle même d'intervenir et
d'affirmer sa politique si plus personne
n'a peur de l'europe en moyen-orient
méditerranée alors en somme dans de
mauvaises situations
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]